DIANE SOLINGER:
I'm Diane Solinger.
I'm the manager of
the GooglersGive team.
We're the team that sits
in people operations,
HR here at Google, that
works with our employees,
so all you great Googlers to
help you give and volunteer
to organizations and
causes that you care about.
And we our largely known
for a couple big things.
One is the Googler
Gift Match Program.
So every Googler
has the opportunity
to make contributions and have
those matched by Google, up
to $6,000 per Googler each year.
So just in case you
didn't know that,
remember your gift
match benefit.
Additionally, we have
donations for doers.
So if you volunteer, every hour
generates $10 in Google support
to the organization
that you volunteer with,
up to $2,500 a year.
And right now you'll see
a couple things happening.
We also launched disaster
matching campaigns.
So there's one
going on right now
to support the flood
relief in India.
And soon, very soon, maybe
within the next hour even,
we will have an Ebola relief
disaster campaign going on.
In that case, Googlers get
an extra $1,000 of gift
match to support those
organizations that
are curated and featured
for those campaigns.
So all those things can be
found at go/googlersgive.
If you want to request
a match, it's go/give.
And for disaster relief,
its' go/givehelp.
So just a little
bit about the team.
We're a global team, 13 people.
We rely on ambassadors.
So anybody interested
in getting more involved
in helping Googlers
get involved,
we are looking for
ambassadors to help us.
We've got about 160
around the world that
help us implement programs and
design things that make sense
for their teams or
for their office,
and join into big
things like this, which
is the Education
for All Campaign.
Education for All is
really what it says.
It's about trying to
help Googlers support
educational
organizations in ways
that mean something to them.
But also to bring us
together as a team,
as a global group of Googlers,
to support a unified cause
that we find Googlers
want to rally around.
Education tends to be
the number one thing
that Googlers are
interested in supporting.
And we find sometimes that it's
kind of analysis paralysis.
What do I do?
There's so many choices.
How do I get involved?
Where should I give?
So the campaign that's
been pulled together
is to really kind of bring
some focus in on education
and provide some
featured organization
choices for donations,
and local volunteering
opportunities for
you to get engaged.
So that is
go/education campaign.
This is part of the
campaign as well.
Because we want to shine
a light on organizations
that provide an education
opportunity for us
to learn more about education
issues and opportunities to get
involved.
So this panel has come
together to address that.
We're really fortunate to
have wonderful people here
to talk about two contexts.
And we're going to lay it
out this way, a little bit
about what's going on in the US.
And we'll have two
wonderful people
involved in that
from DonorsChoose.
And then we'll talk a
little bit about education
outside the U.S. And that
will be focused mostly
on The Philippines.
We are a global company.
And people are
interested in both.
And I think what we'll find
is that, although the U.S. is
a developed countries, there's a
lot of parallels between what's
happening in the
developing world
and what's happening here
with respect to education.
There's a gap no
matter where you look.
And I think people
really want to help.
And that's what we're
here to talk about today.
So to my right is Oliver.
Oliver Hurst-Hiller is the
Chief Technology Officer
for DonorsChoose.
He is also the head of product.
He went to DonorsChoose
in I think 2006.
Is that correct?
OLIVER HURST-HILLER:
That's correct.
DIANE SOLINGER: And he
came from Microsoft.
Ooh!
But he's found the light.
He's helping the world.
And if you want to just
give a little bit more
about your background and what
you're doing at DonorsChoose.
Tell us about DonorsChoose too.
And maybe how Google's
been working with you.
OLIVER HURST-HILLER: Yeah,
so I run a-- first of all,
thank you guys for
having us today.
This is super cool.
I'm sitting up here with a
bestselling author and Grammy
award-winning multi-platinum
recording artists.
I'm like the other guy.
So I'll try to be
brief so you guys can
here from these amazing
panelists sitting next to me.
Yeah, so I run product
and engineering
at DonorsChoose.org.
And we're website where public
school teachers post their best
ideas for classroom
projects that their schools
can't otherwise afford.
Think of it as like a
Kickstarter for classrooms.
Folks on the internet help
bring these projects to life.
Many people don't know this.
Unlike say an eBay,
or a Kickstarter,
we don't then send a check.
We actually fulfill
the project ourselves.
So if it's resources,
we deliver them.
If it's a field trip, we
pay the bus company directly
and help make the
field trip happen.
It works.
It's amazing.
It was founded 14 years
ago by a public school
teacher in the Bronx.
And it spread from
his classroom,
to the rest of the Bronx, to
the rest of New York City.
It's now nationwide.
We've done more
than $260 million
in donations to
classrooms [INAUDIBLE],
more than 12 million students
on the receiving end.
More than half of the public
schools in the country
have a teacher who's
used the website, which
is kind of staggering.
There's more than 95,000 public
schools in the United States.
So we're really
proud of that reach.
And what else can I add?
Some of the most innovative
things that we've done,
we've done with Google.
So I want to take a moment
to thank you guys for that,
and also to remind you of them.
Because Google has been
a special partner for us.
Because Google is
willing to take
risks with us, and
willing to experiment,
and willing to be
innovative, and find
ways to advance both
of our missions.
So one thing we've
done together is around
getting more AP science,
engineering, and math classes
into under-served communities.
And so we're partnering with
Google and College Board,
and essentially putting
incentives in place
for the teachers
at that school who
have students that
show potential
to excel in these areas,
but are essentially
under-served by the
courses aren't there.
So we put incentives in
place to start new AP classes
in those areas.
Or if there are AP classes,
to add enrollment, and extend
them, and get resources to them.
And that's an amazing program.
We do that with Google, and with
the College Board, like I said.
DIANE SOLINGER: Can I
ask you something else?
You raised another--
Google has granted funds
through Google.org
to DonorsChoose.
And there's another grantee
that is called Equal Opportunity
Schools that is working
kind of in that same space.
Are they involved in helping
identify the students that
might be part of
those AP classes?
Is there some collaboration
between these two grantees?
OLIVER HURST-HILLER:
There might be.
DIANE SOLINGER: It might be
Google.org in the background.
[INAUDIBLE].
OLIVER HURST-HILLER:
It might be Google
behind the scenes
putting it all together.
For us, part of the role
of the College Board
is that because the College
Board sees test results
for students well before they
would get to the AP level--
so, for example, the PSATs.
And it turns out, the PSATs
are a pretty good predictor--
we can all say what we want
about standardized tests.
But in underrepresented
communities, African American
and Latino communities,
they are representative
of high potential.
So with the College Board,
they can say to us, look,
we know this school
has high potential
for advanced courses
in the STEM areas.
But there's no AP classes there.
Because they also know where
there's AP classes because they
administer the tests.
So in that way,
College Board has
been a partner which works
with us in order to help focus.
Another thing we've done
together that was super cool
was helping get more
girls learning to code.
And we've done with partnership
with Google, and Khan Academy,
and Code Academy.
And obviously there's so
much excitement and interest
around this issue.
But actually moving the
ball forward is hard.
And a bunch of forces,
societal and otherwise,
are working against
us historically.
And I think it's a
really innovate way
they're trying to
lick the problem.
And so basically if
a teacher or-- we
incentives in place for
teachers and students
to essentially take
coding courses.
And then the teacher
will get a reward
in the form of dollars
they can bring resources
to their classroom, and
same for the students.
And the last thing I'll
mention is really neat.
We did it this year
for back to school.
And it started in the Bay
Area, and ended just a week ago
in Detroit.
For 11 communities
across the country,
Google backed what we call a
surprise flash funding, where
it's like-- we have
videos of this.
And it will make you cry.
So the students, and
teachers, and administrators
are invited an event.
They think they're
going to get some grant
and other things
are going to happen.
And basically it's revealed
to them at that moment
that Google has funded
for back to school
every single classroom request
in that entire community.
And these aren't
small communities.
It's like Bay Area,
Detroit, Seattle, big ones.
And everybody just goes bananas.
And the Googlers walk
in carrying the stuff.
And everybody's
crying and hugging.
It's an amazing to
start the school year.
So thank you guys
for backing that.
DIANE SOLINGER: I
think it was amazing,
from what I've heard
out of that too.
I mentioned Equal Opportunity
School is another grantee.
But when you talked about
Khan Academy and code.org,
they're also organizations
that Google works with.
So in some ways, I think,
which is wonderful for me
to hear as a Googler, but
to remind myself also,
I think we have a lot of power
as a company to be a convener,
and to bring these
organizations together
who have different skill
sets and sets of expertise.
So, again, you've
got what you do.
Khan and Code do what they do.
And here we are
seeing the landscape,
and trying to bring
it all together
so that we can have the
most impact together.
OLIVER HURST-HILLER:
It's so cool.
DIANE SOLINGER:
Yeah, it's awesome.
So if I was a
teacher-- well, here's
a story, a little vignette.
So I know someone who was on
the board of a small charter
school in San Francisco.
The school did not know
about [INAUDIBLE] at all.
And then they saw the whole
Bay Area surprise stuff
happening, which was wonderful.
The teachers didn't
know about it.
So where you talk a little
bit about the business
model and such, you say
guerrilla marketing,
would you say that?
How are teachers
learning about this?
And how does the general public
know how to get involved?
OLIVER HURST-HILLER: It's funny.
When Charles Best-- who's
the public school teacher who
founded the org and still
runs it 14 years later--
when he founded the organization
in his classroom in the Bronx--
we have a marketplace.
Think of it as like a
philanthropic marketplace.
On the one side are teachers
with their requests.
On the other side are what we
call citizen donors, and then
also corporate backers.
When he started
the organization,
he had to do a lot of work on
both sides of that marketplace
to have the liquidity to
make the whole thing work.
He had to sort of basically
bribe teachers to use the site.
Because if a website has never
given a dollar to a classroom,
why would a teacher
who's so busy
spend their time putting
a request up there.
And then he also had
to bring donors there
with just a couple
projects on the site.
Saying, well, it's
all about choice,
But actually there's
only eight projects there
because we started a month ago.
So initially, he had to
spend a ton of effort
making the market.
And when I joined the
org eight years ago,
we had staff members
who were focused
on driving awareness
among teachers.
And, fortunately, in 2014, we
now have a level of awareness,
with the exception of maybe
that school and other schools--
DIANE SOLINGER:
It's a small school.
OLIVER HURST-HILLER: But we
have a level of awareness
where the teachers are
coming to our site.
And they're asking for stuff
that they can't get elsewhere.
And we're really racing
on the citizen donor side,
racing to keep up
with that demand,
and trying to find innovative
ways to get them funding.
So at this point,
it's essentially
like a word of mouth thing.
For example, when you're
on boarded at Teach
for America, when they take
this recent college grad.
And they say, hey, you're about
to dive into a challenging
situation at high needs
school, part of their briefing
includes DonorsChoose.org
You go here.
And this is where you get
the resources you need.
So the good news is that the
word of mouth has taken over.
And we have a lot of work
to do with Google's help,
and get those projects funded.
DIANE SOLINGER: Are
you seeing any trends
in what teachers are needing?
And what people are
interested in funding?
OLIVER HURST-HILLER: Yeah, so
I would say-- one of the things
that people may not realize
until they visit the site
and actually look at
the classroom requests
is that-- you see some of
the stuff, which is just,
we have a rug.
It's disgusting.
It's 10 years old.
The kids sit on it
every day to read.
Can we have a new rug?
Or we need paper.
How can we do anything
without paper?
So sometime's it's these
really basic essentials--
DIANE SOLINGER: We don't
like paper at Google.
Get the Chrome books.
OLIVER HURST-HILLER: We have
those requests too, actually.
So sometimes it's for
these basic essentials.
You just can't run a
classroom without it.
But many of the
requests are teachers
who are looking to be
innovators in their classrooms.
They're looking to
be experimental.
try something new.
It might be a book
that's never bee
taught for this
particular curriculum.
Or it might be a
piece of technology
which the school's not yet
using in the classroom.
But they're a
little tech forward.
And they want to try.
And it's just, as
you can imagine,
there isn't a natural
budgeting way in the way
that schools are
funded today, in terms
of the district and the
school, for teachers
to think outside the
box, and they get money
to think outside the box.
It's like you're
really just hoping
you got the money
you got last year.
And so one of the most
exciting things for us
is seeing the stuff
on the site where
the teachers are
being innovative.
And they're outside the box.
And they're trying something
new, and taking a risk.
And then citizen
donors, this person
hasn't had to go through sort
of the whole bureaucracy,
and champion an
idea which may fail.
And you guys know about the
value of experimentation.
So one of these we're
very excited about
is that many of the
projects are in that area.
It's not just meeting a need
that should already be met.
It's helping a teacher be an
innovator on the front liens.
DIANE SOLINGER: So we're
going to move it over
to Tim for a few questions.
So Tim Ferriss, best selling
author, entrepreneur,
does everything in fours.
We're only four people today.
You joined the board
of DonorsChoose.
So tell us more
about your story,
and why you made that choice.
TIM FERRISS: Sure.
So I'm on the advisory
board of DonorsChoose.
I have been involved
probably close to ten years
now, very long time.
But just as context, which
I think is important,
I'm very, very
cynical of nonprofits.
I think the vast majority
waste most of what
they receive from donors.
And you don't know
where it goes.
It's sloppy.
They hire people who
couldn't get jobs
at for profit companies.
This sounds terrible.
But it's true.
More so than even
the publishing,
my career is investing
on this new startup.
So I was pre-seed
money adviser to Uber.
I think I was first advisor
to Evernote, early Twitter.
I mean, I apply the exact same
level of rigor and analysis
to the nonprofits
that I back, which
is why I support
so few nonprofits.
DonorsChoose is run like a
lean, mean, aggressive, smart
for profit company.
And they're able to hire
talent to support that.
An the story for me
goes way, way back.
Because, of course, part
of vetting any startup
is getting to know
the management team.
I know the founder Charles
Best extremely well
because we were wrestling
partners in high school.
And he always beat my
sorry ass by one point
for the varsity spot.
So I know Charles
really, really well.
DIANE SOLINGER: He's
a determined guy.
TIM FERRISS: And we've
kept close for a long time.
And we share very
similar values.
And I think that DonorsChoose
shares a lot of similar values
with most Googlers.
And I've spent a lot of time
here, and at the Googleplex,
and with a lot of people
who have worked for Google.
DonorsChoose for me is
important for a few reasons.
Number one is, a lot of people
in this room, I suspect,
feel strongly about education.
And perhaps you're like me.
You recognize that there are few
inflection points in your life
where you had an opportunity.
You had a particular teacher.
You had a particular project.
You had a particular
type of support
where you could
have gone this way.
And instead you went this way.
And for me, that
was especially true
in second grade, fifth grade,
ninth grade, and tenth grade.
I remember the exact teachers
and the exact projects.
And I want to
encourage everybody.
If you're king about
education, what I realized
is you can't fix education
any more than you
can sort of fix violence or war.
You have to thin slice it.
And DonorsChoose
allows you to do that.
So for my case, I care about a
couple of things very deeply.
I care about literacy.
I care about numeracy.
And I care about STEM.
And even though I'm not
an engineer by training,
I have a lot of the
basics, the fundamentals,
of letter and number comfort
given to me through education.
And that has allowed everything
that has come after this.
This is cliche.
But if you want to
teach people to fish
and not just give
them a fish, you
have to give them
the toolkit that
allows them to be critical
problem solvers and creators.
And you need to be literate.
You need to have
numeracy for that.
So what I would do
is with the help--
and the only reason
I've been supporting it
for 10 years instead
of 14 is because no one
knew who the hell
it was 14 years ago.
They needed a platform first to
really do what I wanted to do.
And so I've funded projects
with the help of my readers
for about 200,000
students so far.
Every year, and just from
a tactical standpoint,
I will choose projects
very specifically
that are related to
STEM or literacy.
And I'll tell people, and my
readers, go to the zip code
where you grew up.
Support those projects in the
schools where you grew up.
If you want to fix the
problems where you grew up,
I grew up on Long Island.
That's like a black
hole in some places.
People don't get out.
People die of drug overdoses.
A lot of my friends
have, because they
went the other way.
And I got these opportunities.
And just a couple
of recommendations.
Number one is look
under your seat.
I have three $1,000 gift
cards to DonorsChoose.
So sort of this is Willy
Wonka style for you guys.
So you can check under your
seats before you leave.
DIANE SOLINGER: They're
all checking now.
TIM FERRISS: There's
three $1,000 gift cards.
And if you found them,
if you hate kids,
definitely don't use them.
DIANE SOLINGER: I don't
think they hate them.
TIM FERRISS: Otherwise,
please put it to use.
There we go.
Should be.
[CHEERING]
TIM FERRISS: That's
step number one.
Step number two is I encourage
you, rather than perhaps
developing a really
detrimental drug habit
elsewhere is fund one project
on DonorsChoose, one project.
Or just help a project.
And it'll develop into this sort
of benevolent drug hit for you.
DIANE SOLINGER: You just gave
them the first hit for free.
TIM FERRISS: When I'm
having a bad day-- so
what else do I look for in for
profit startups and nonprofit?
I look for transparency.
I look for metrics.
I look forward feedback.
I look for an iterative
product development loop.
You guys focus on product.
If I were to compare you
to anyone in my startups,
I'd say yeah, Evernote.
If it's $1,000 in PR,
or $1,000 in product,
it's $1,000 in
product, every time.
And when you fund a
project, you get feedback.
So I have-- and I'm not sure
if this is the case anymore
because of how you guys are
tweaking everything to scale.
I think it's more digital now.
But I have a drawer
full of thank
you letters from teachers.
And when I'm having a hard day,
when I'm just, I can't do it.
God, I suck.
Life is so hard.
You know, just
one of those days.
We all have them.
I sit down.
Pour myself a cup of tea.
And, very San Francisco, and
read through these letters.
And I swear to you,
it can help you.
You will get as much
out of it as you
are giving to these
teachers and these students.
So that's the pitch.
I don't feel like it's
even a hard pitch.
Because you look at
the number of converts,
these are not people who
openly endorse a lot of stuff.
You've got Oprah.
You've got Stephen Colbert.
You've Biz Stone.
You've got Michelle Obama.
It's a hell of an organization.
And they're very lean.
They're very effective.
And it's very, very specific.
Because you can't boil the
ocean and try to fix education.
It's too big.
You need to thin slice it.
Just like organizing
the world's information.
Great, you can't
make that one project
and put it into like a timeline.
You have to create pods.
And I DonorsChoose is
a very effective sort
of Seal Team 6 version
if you're looking
at these particular
types of projects,
for me, focusing on K12.
DIANE SOLINGER: So with
respect to the whole genesis
of DonorsChoose.
[INAUDIBLE] as a
teacher, we need things.
Our classrooms are under-funded.
Where is DonorsChoose getting
more involved in advocacy?
I know we can't solve it all.
We can't boil the ocean.
But you do have advocates
like Michelle Obama
saying this is great.
So are you stepping into
that policy discussion
more as an organization?
OLIVER HURT-HILLER: Policy
and advocacy is important.
It's also difficult.
And it may not be-- one
of the things that's
made us successful, Tim
would probably tell you,
is that we're sort of focused
on doing what we do really well,
and not getting too distracted.
But we are excited
about the idea
of having an impact
beyond just direct relief.
And so to your question, one of
the things we're starting to do
is dig into our data.
And we now actually have
a data science team.
It's two people.
But that's still
unusual for a nonprofit.
And our attitude is
we've got, we believe,
the most innovative teachers in
the United States on our site.
And they're requesting
resources for their classroom.
And like I said
before, sometimes it's
critical stuff they
should have already.
And sometimes, often, it's
outside of the box stuff.
These teachers are
ahead of the curve.
And they're asking
for certain things
to teach math, or certain
things to teach technology,
or literacy, that they're
ahead of other teachers.
And they may be ahead
of budget makers.
So our first foray into
this is, and still very much
at the beginning an experiment,
is to dig into that data,
and say, what are our
teachers telling us?
And what trends are we seeing?
And I'll give you
a simple example.
For a while, there's been a
long push towards, for example,
Smart Boards.
And Smart Boards are great.
But they're also
quite expensive.
And what we've seen
more often requested
are what are called
ELMO projectors.
It's basically the
modern overhead.
So many of us grew up with
a traditional overhead.
And this is the modern one where
you can put anything on it,
you can plug in your
computer, et cetera.
And these are on the order
of hundreds of dollars.
So this is just a
very simple example,
where we see teachers
saying, well,
given a choice between
these technologies,
I'm going to go for
this cheaper one.
And Smart Boards
are still awesome.
And this can be
informative in many ways.
So maybe we can impact budgets.
Maybe we can impact policy.
Maybe we can show
mainstream teachers
what these teachers who are out
in front, what they're doing,
and kind of pass that down.
DIANE SOLINGER: That's kind
of what I was going to ask.
TIM FERRISS: Well,
let me jump in, too.
So you guys understand
the power of data.
Or put a different
way, data when
you're able to convert it
into meaningful information.
So I'm going to take
it a step further.
Hypothetically, this
is not a conversation
I've had with DonorsChoose.
OLIVER HURT-HILLER:
Let's do it now.
TIM FERRISS: The views are my
own [INAUDIBLE] say on Twitter.
Hypothetically, what happens?
You have data.
You have information
on what types of things
are needed in which districts.
OK.
People, generally, in
a given county, state,
they want their education
to be really good.
So what happens when you have a
handful of politicians running,
some of them for
re-election, and you're
able to say, wow,
that district really
sucks for these
following things.
You're just not taking
care of your educators.
And, hypothetically,
you would have the data
to be able to apply,
again, this sort
of karma-cly positive
pressure to say, hey,
if you look at all
these 10 counties,
here are the three that
are the worst performing.
You want to get
re-elected, you better
propose a solution
that addresses that.
So it's a very powerful
data set that I
think could be harnessed at some
point, hypothetically speaking.
Tactically, I just
want to just touch
on a couple super
tactical things.
So there are a handful of really
effective nonprofits out there.
If you give to any
nonprofit-- of course,
I would hope that you
give a chunk, at least,
to DonorsChoose.org because
they make such good use of it.
A couple things,
number one is take
advantage of the
matching, no-brainer.
So one thing that I do every
year, I do $100,000 birthday
give back, where I say,
hey, I will match up
to $50,000 whatever you guys
can raise on this project page.
And my readers always hit it.
But how can you make
that more interesting?
You can make it more
interesting if I say,
instead of donating $1,000 in
cash, donate $1,000 in stock.
So there are a couple different
ways that's beneficial.
So you can either have
Google match, which is great.
You can also, in
an ideal world--
I'm not sure this is
mechanically possibly.
But you donate stock,
what does that mean?
So instead of selling your stock
for $100, paying $30 in tax,
then donating $70, you
donate 100% of that value
to the nonprofit.
I never realized this until
like a year or two ago.
Because people don't explain it.
It's just, God, that's
such an obvious thing.
And so many people
do not realize it,
because it's very
seldom explained.
OLIVER HURT-HILLER:
How the match
would work with that, guys.
Is we would match the cash
value of what you transferred.
TIM FERRISS: Perfect.
OLIVER HURT-HILLER: Oh, wow.
DIANE SOLINGER: Up to $6,000.
TIM FERRISS: So if you
have the option, then,
you make the stock donation
instead of the cash donation.
Why?
Because not only are you
giving more to the nonprofit
if you look at certain
aspects of taxation.
You get 100% of the
write-off value, also.
So, anyway, just
super tactically,
I would say, get
depreciated stock,
it's a fantastic way to go.
Especially that it's going
to matched for the cash value
by this wonderful organization
I've heard of called Google.
DIANE SOLINGER: Final
question for you guys
before we transition
a little bit.
You've got this whole
network-- if you
had to describe what I
am on the connectors,
I always say to help
people connect together.
And you've got this
network of teachers.
You've got these
forward-thinking,
innovative teachers,
and then maybe
ones that don't
know what could be.
Are you convening these folks?
Or sharing the stories
amongst them more digitally?
Do you have some
kind of community
where they're coming together?
OLIVER HURT-HILLER:
Practically, tactically speaking
it happens already in the
sense that teachers will look
on our site for things that
have been funded by teachers
in a similar circumstance,
similar grade,
similar subjects.
And they'll look
there for inspiration.
Like, what are they getting
for their classroom?
And if the project got
funded, by how many donors,
because that's revealing of
the market's sort of appetite
for those sorts of projects--
TIM FERRISS: Can I-- I just
want to also just chime in here.
Because there's something
that is sort of so
intrinsic to your DNA that
sometimes people don't get it
explicitly, which is they
vet all the products.
So if a teacher is like, I
need a new huge, big screen TV.
This Samsung would be ideal.
Like, they look into
that, and make sure--
OLIVER HURT-HILLER:
That's right.
We'll only ship to the school
with a bunch of things in place
to make sure there's
no funny business.
Remind me where we were.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DIANE SOLINGER: You said the
marketplace is giving you
the information.
OLIVER HURT-HILLER: Right,
so the teachers are already,
on sort of a per project basis,
learning from each other.
But I think one opportunity that
we haven't really exploited,
which is real exciting
to me, is what
do you do if you have the most
innovative teachers in America
all on one website or service.
And a lot of people have, should
I be sharing lesson plans?
Should I be sharing curriculum?
Should they just be supporting
each other in an emotional way?
Because the truth is,
it's a lonely profession.
They spend most of their days
not with their colleagues.
They spend their
day with students.
That's what they believe in.
That's what they're there for.
But they have tough days.
And even some of
their best friends
may not teach in the same grade,
or teach in the same subject.
They may be the history
teacher at the school.
Could we connect them with
other history teachers
facing similar challenges?
So I think we see it
as a big opportunity.
And we're fortunate.
A lot of sites have said, OK,
lots of teachers come here.
We'll have a network effect.
And then great
things will happen.
But they've have a hard
time getting critical mass.
And we've got the critical mass.
And I think now challenge
and kind of thing
we have to brainstorm
with great advisers
like Time is what do we do
with that now that they're all
coming here?
DIANE SOLINGER: [INAUDIBLE]
product integration plan, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE].
Thank you.
We'll be having questions later.
So don't worry.
But wanted to
transition a little bit.
We've been talking a
lot about DonorsChoose,
and things that are happening
here in the United States,
and Google's involvement there.
Takl a little bit now
about aple.de.ap, and what
he's been doing, particularly
in The Philippines.
We've got a video we're going
to show about the Aple.de.ap
Foundation.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What would you do
for someone else?
-A stranger on the
far side of the world?
-Would it even matter?
Would it make a difference?
-What would you do
for someone else?
-Growing up, aple.de.ap
was that someone,
that stranger on the
far side of the world,
desperately poor, barely
educated, and half blind.
What could he give in return?
Surely, there were better bets.
Joe Ben Hudgins is
an incredible guy.
When he learned about this
kid in the Philippines,
he brought Apple to America.
And he got him that eye surgery
that he so vitally needed.
Joe adopted Apple.
And Apple met Will I Am.
The two formed the most unlikely
pair that you could imagine.
-First time at Apple,
he was in ninth grade.
He didn't speak English.
I didn't really
know what to think.
Because we couldn't communicate.
Then we finally found a way
to talk that was just dancing.
So we'd go to practice at
the rec room for hours, dude.
-Then they formed a
crew, began competing.
From there, through
hardship and hard work,
they grew into the
Black Eyed Peas.
-Because I had that other
perspective of poverty
to fight for something,
just that confidant
right next to you, like,
we're going to do it.
Forget what they say.
We're going to make it happen.
-Soon the group rocketed
to international success,
world tours, six Grammys, 56
million records sold, the World
Cup, and the Super Bowl.
But through it all Apple's
heart never strayed far
from his homeland.
In his thoughts
and in his dreams,
he would turn again, and
again, wanting to help,
wanting to give back, to
do what Joe taught him.
Don't sit around.
Do what you can.
And do it now.
-You rarely meet someone who
is as caring and generous
as Apple.
He's always helping others.
He really loves his country
so much, with his whole heart.
-So Apple formed the
Aple.de.ap Foundation.
And he used it to build schools.
Apple built awareness,
raised funds,
and joined with President
of the Philippines
to create the You Can
be Anything Campaign
[MUSIC PLAYING APLE.DE.AP, "WE
CAN BE ANYTHING"]
-But that's only the start.
The Aple.de.ap
Foundation is working
to establish classrooms,
and schools, and labs all
across the Philippines.
-When I look at Ap,
it makes me proud.
Proud of his dedication, his
passion, how humble he is.
He's done a lot.
But I think Apple's
just getting started.
My sincere thanks for
all you have done.
I have to admit
from time to time,
I like to enjoy and sometimes
dance to aple.de.ap's hip hop
anthems.
And it certainly helps
my enjoyment knowing
that the man singing
on the record
has consistency,
may I repeat that,
has consistently given
back to this nation.
-One person cannot
change the world.
But if I help somebody
here, you help someone here,
and we come together, then
we can make a difference.
-Joe Hudgins didn't wait.
He gave because he could.
he gave because he cared.
-When you help someone, you
often don't know who they are,
or what they have
to give, or how
they might help someone
else down the road.
-What matters is
that you take action.
Take that step.
Give.
Do.
-Be a part of the
love in the world.
-What would you do
for someone else?
[MUSIC PLAYING BLACK EYED PEAS,
"WHERE IS THE LOVE?"]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DIANE SOLINGER: I think
the love in this room.
And I have a
question for you, how
did Fergie get to a
Google micro kitchen?
Did anybody notice
that in the video?
It looked like she
was in [INAUDIBLE].
Anyway, Apple, welcome.
APLE.DE.AP: Thank you.
DIANE SOLINGER: And thank
you for sharing you story,
and for doing what you're doing.
It's phenomenal.
Your personal journey is
just a wonderful story.
We saw it there.
But just tell us
in your own words,
how did you get to where you
are, and what you're doing?
APLE.DE.AP: OK.
First of all, thank you
for having me here today.
It's always exciting, and very
informative being in Google.
And I heard there's a giveaway
for them Google Glasses.
Anyway.
So I grew up in a
small province called
Sapang Boto, Angeles
City, in the Philippines.
And, you know, I
can still remember
where the electric grid
wasn't even in my town yet.
We were still using
kerosene and stuff.
And I used to tag along
with my grandfather farming,
making charcoal, planting sweet
potatoes, and corns, and stuff.
But what's interesting
is, we were poor.
But it didn't feel like it.
It didn't feel like it.
Because my mom was
very resourceful.
We had what you call
a sari-sari store.
That means like a 7-11
in front of your house.
And my Mom would
package charcoal,
and make her own sashays of oil.
And I'm like the delivery
boy that delivers it
throughout the province, all
the little stores in my town.
DIANE SOLINGER: So she was
the distribution center
for all these things?
APLE.DE.AP: Yeah,
I was the delivery
boy to distribute the sashays
that she'd been making,
and so on.
And I guess she found out about
a foundation called Pearl S.
Buck Foundation where they
support immigration kids.
And I guess I was qualified.
And, you know, I was in
one of those commercials,
send $0.75 a day to a
kid in The Philippines.
And I made sure my
shirt was really dirty.
[LAUGHTER]
APLE.DE.AP: And then,
in return, so you
get sponsors from the U.S. And
they send you school supplies.
And in return, you
get to write letters.
And actually show
your grades, your GPA.
And that's why education
is very important.
Learning English, simple
as learning English,
I was able to tell
my story to my Dad.
Because, you know,
of course you're
supposed to impress your
sponsor to have good grades,
and the mind is going
the right places.
So I would always tell
stories like, Dad, you know,
I'm sorry that my GPA
in math is kind of low.
Because I have an eye problem.
I cannot see the board.
And I'm always playing
catch up, trying
to copy the notes
from my classmates.
So just telling him
different stories,
and how hard it was
in The Philippines
that he decided to adopt me.
And that brought me
to the U.S. in 1989.
And he was roommate
with Will i Am's uncle.
So on the weekdays, he
needed a babysitter.
So Will i Am's uncle's
like, well, Joe, you
know my sister Deborah
could take care of Alvin
during the weekdays.
He was a tall black man.
That's why I--
So and she has a kid
the same age as Allen.
So now I'm living in Los Feliz
area, which is pretty cool,
not the ghetto.
And then they took me to East
L.A. and out to Will's house.
And I'm like, yes, this
is where I want to live.
Because it just had that
sense of family, and just
everyone playing outside.
Of course, I met Will.
It was a culture shock,
coming from Philippines
10,000 miles away.
Now I'm in East L.A. And I'm
like, power windows, I'm like,
huh!
And then me and Will we're
just kind of like, you know.
It's after four hours later,
finally we start conversing.
He's like, so, you're
from The Philippines?
It's like, yeah.
So, uh.
So what do you do there?
What do you do there?
I know how to running man.
Running man.
He's like you know how
to do the running man all
the way from the Philippines?
I hope you didn't run from the
Philippines all the way here.
So from that conversation, we
just shared the same interests.
Like, yeah, I break dance too.
And then we formed a dance
group called Tribal Nation.
And we were 16, 17.
So all we could do was go
to Filipino house parties.
And get shot up.
Ah!
Time to go home.
And then, of course,
we had a dance group.
We were battling everyone.
Like, yeah, you want it?
You want it?
Yeah!
[LAUGHTER]
So we were kind of
running this scene.
And then a friend of hours was
like, yo, you guys ain't sh!
You guys ain't nothing
until you go to Hollywood.
We're like, oh, yeah, Hollywood?
All right.
So we started
going to Hollywood.
And started joining
dance contests,
and MC battles and stuff.
And one day Eazy
E's A&R was there.
You know, Eazy E from NWA.
He had his A&&R come
just scouting and stuff.
So his A&R saw us.
And he's like, yo,
you guys got a demo?
Let's have a meeting.
My boss is Easy E, NWA.
It's like, yeah?
All right.
So long story short, we
got signed to Eazy E.
And then he passed away.
We couldn't use that
album, our own names,
because of whatever--
for contract reasons.
So Eazy E passed away in '95.
And then we started
Black Eyed Peas.
And just kept doing
shows, shows, shows.
Back then, there was no email,
no Twitter, no Facebook.
So then we would chuck our
demos to the record companies.
We were more into Tribe
Called Quest, break dancing.
It was more positive.
And L.A. back in the days was
more like, NWA, all gangster
music.
So the record companies didn't
think it was tangible enough.
DIANE SOLINGER: So
along the way, though,
because we've got an hour--
APLE.DE.AP: So anyway, so we
started our own following.
We started our own
following And then
Black Eyed Peas came about.
And then finally
after a decade later,
I was able to go back home.
And then I just started
seeing the discrepancy
of the education
compared to the U.S.
and all the kids
in my neighborhood.
So we would go on holidays.
And I'm like, yo, what
are these kids doing?
They're just like running
around doing nothing.
So I came up with the
idea, one night, I
was researching in
the club, researching,
and then I called my Mom.
I was like, Mom!
I got a great idea!
I need you to buy a building!
And I'm going to go
home for Christmas!
And bring 25 laptops!
And all the kids
in the neighborhood
can go and learn how to
like-- just learn computers.
And then, it's like,
Allan, son, are you drunk?
I was like, Mom, I
was researching, OK?
I was researching.
And, anyways.
So we built the first computer
labs in my town, Angeles City.
It had 25 desktops.
And I come back
six months later.
And these kids are like
editing their own videos,
taking courses online.
They're GPAs had gone up.
And now they're qualified
to go to university.
So with anything that
is on the video, Grammys
or anything like that,
this is more gratifying
than anything is to be able
to help another person.
So we've been
building classrooms
for about three years now.
We have over 40 classrooms
throughout Philippines.
But, you know, about a
year ago, Typhoon Yolanda
hit The Philippines.
And we had to do
a different turn.
And now we're doing a
music and art therapy
program for the kids.
Because they're traumatized.
They have separation anxiety.
They don't want to go to school.
So we try to make it more fun.
So we have a teacher's
teaching program
to teach the kids
through music and art
to make it fun and enticing
to go back to school again.
And, of course, beyond
that, I have 14 scholars.
And one of them
is valedictorian.
And they're on the
top two percentile.
So I'm always like, what's next?
What's next for these kids?
Of course, to find jobs.
So hopefully I'll get some
volunteers from Google
to mentor these
kids to find jobs,
and, of course,
to have a career.
What else?
DIANE SOLINGER: You're
pretty nimble, though.
I think you went
back-- well, when
you were doing
your research, you
saw that there was
something you could fill,
like build a school.
Then it moved to classrooms.
Then it now is thinking, how
do we support the whole kids?
Thinking about their wellness.
And now the future is jobs.
So it's kind of
a whole continuum
that you're looking at with your
foundation, which is terrific.
APLE.DE.AP: Yeah,
you know, coming in.
Thanks to my
management and my team,
they're teaching about
scaling, like scaling it up.
DIANE SOLINGER:
This is a good place
to learn about scale, too.
APLE.DE.AP: Yeah, so that's
where we at right now.
And really just thinking
of sustaining it,
and keeping it moving, and have
somewhere to go for these kids
after.
My big dream is to have
an academy at the end.
So everyone could
go to this academy,
and learn coding,
learn how to-- I mean,
Curious George is
made in Philippines.
So imagine given
an oppotrunity--
DIANE SOLINGER: You
need a yellow hat.
The man with the yellow hat.
APLE.DE.AP: So that's
where we at right now.
That's where the foundation is.
And just really
coming over here,
I want to really
collaborate with everyone.
Give me ideas.
And I'm very transparent, too.
Just like you said earlier, I
like to see it happen hands on.
Because if I don't,
I lose motivation.
DIANE SOLINGER: I think that's
something a lot of volunteers
look for, too.
When we're
volunteering or giving,
we want to understand that
we're having an impact.
And both organizations
are trying
demonstrate that and share that.
But you're also good
at bringing in people
and having ideas,
which is great.
I don't know if a lot of people
know-- we've got Jimmy here.
But several Googlers-- what was
it a cohort of about 15, 16?
AUDIENCE: It was 16 volunteers,
and then four Googlers leading.
DIANE SOLINGER: So 20 Googlers
went to The Philippines
not too long ago to do a Google
REACH program, three and a half
weeks, and working on
pro bono volunteering.
So think about things like that.
In your own
volunteer experience,
if you want to go
for a deep dive,
that will probably happen again.
And then we have
Google REACH in Delhi,
and coming up in Accra, Ghana.
And we do REACH local,
which is wrapping up
this week in the Bay
Area and in Seattle.
This week it's been
focused on education.
So you can do a deep dive
with an education organization
in your background.
But, again, go to
go/googlersgive
for some of those ideas.
If you want to get involved.
I think we should
open to all of you.
Are there questions
out in the audience?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming,
really insightful stuff.
I appreciate your time.
So I guess I'm wondering-- you
talked a little bit about it
already-- but networking.
So one of the most
important things
that I think is a big part of
why we're successful at Google
is because we're very good at
sharing knowledge, and passing
learnings along from
organization to organization.
So you talked a little bit about
how teachers can proactively
go and check out what other
projects are being funded,
and that sort of thing.
But is there anything
to kind of preemptively
push that type of
behavior on to teachers?
And is there
anything that you can
do to kind of encourage that so
that these people are talking?
And they could see
what's successful
and what's not to kind of
help set them up for success?
OLIVER HURST-HILLER: I
think to some degree,
we touched on this.
I think maybe we can
do this with our data.
But we're still at
very early stages.
I think maybe we can do
it with all these teachers
that are coming to our site.
And by the way, when we email
them, they're paying attention.
Because it often has
to do with funds,
resources for their classrooms.
So we have their attention.
So I think there's a
lot of opportunity there
that's untapped.
One thing I will say in terms
of sharing and knowledge
dissemination that
I'm super excited
is that-- I spent my career
prior to DonorsChoose.org
in the for profit commercial
internet software sector.
Companies collaborate
on some things.
But there's just a lot you can't
share for competitive reasons.
And one of the great things
about working in this sector
is that organizations I
think are much quicker
to share with each other.
So just last week,
we had a gathering
that we do once a year
of the CTOs of some
of the most innovative,
tech forward
nonprofits in the country.
We did it last year in New York.
This year it was
in San Francisco.
It's us, and Kiva, and
Global Giving, and Wikimedia.
They run a really big website.
It's called [INAUDIBLE]
pretty popular.
And Charity: Water,
and Common Sense Media,
which is also based here.
And we get together.
And we spend two days just
totally sharing everything.
What are your
toughest challenges?
What technologies are you using?
How are you collaborating
with other orgs?
And I just get so much from it.
Our org gets so
much fun from it.
And this is just only
possible in our sector.
Because there's this feeling
of we're not competing.
We all have a
similar motivation.
And that's actually
inspired what
we call CMOs for good, which
is the marketing folks.
And now we've got COOs for good.
So now we've got all
the head of operations
at these different orgs
talking and sharing.
So, to me, that's a
level up from what
you asked about in
terms of the teachers.
But I think it's exciting
in terms of a rising tide,
just us not having to make all
the same mistakes on our own,
and learning from each other.
DIANE SOLINGER: Intersting,
though, the organizations
you mentioned you mentioned
are all pretty new.
So I was in the nonprofit
sector for over 25 years.
A lot of those organizations
that I used to work for
would not have thought
about that collaboration
that you're thinking about.
And that's what's really
going to make the impact.
It's so good to hear.
TIM FERRISS: Just to add to
that, if I could real fast.
There are kind of two
levels of collaboration,
the CTO to CTO, which is
organization to organization
collab is really important.
But I think the-- more
when I met with Charles
along with Scott
of Charity: Water,
I thought that they could
trade, for instance,
their pairing of
birthday gift bags,
which Charity: Water was very
good at with DonorsChoose'
ability to get corporate
support, which can just
be just be a force multiplier.
On the teacher-- just as a
donor, this might be helpful.
What I've seen is the planned,
and then the organic plan,
I think you guys do
a very job of email,
of utilizing the
database of emails,
which includes a
lot of teachers.
Second would be, I think
a lot of the collaboration
could be accomplished very
easily, for instance, not
necessarily through reddit.
But reddit's been
a huge supporter.
And I think that you
could very easily see it,
if it's not already there.
I mean, every time,
I'm like, oh, I
should create a
subreddit about blah,
it's like there are
already 12 of them.
So I would be surprised if
they don't already exist.
But if they don't, it
would actually, I think,
very easy to thin
slice into my subject
to stay both on
something like reddit.
DIANE SOLINGER: Question?
AUDIENCE: First, I wanted
to thank the Give team
for bringing the panelists.
I love that this a
spectrum of the world.
So we're looking
at The Philippines,
and what's being done here in
the U.S. But what I also love
is the spectrum of the startup
and established foundation.
So my question, which I'd love
for all of you to address,
is how you see-- a
lot of times with we
come to these summits and talks.
And we're inspired.
And we want to take
things forward.
But how do each of you,
like now meeting each other
for the first time, plan
to bring it forward?
Like, what can the Philippines
learn from you, and vice versa?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I know that you
guys are nationally focused.
But I also look at
you as like, OK,
you're a grownup foundation.
And so there's a lot
that a startup foundation
can learn from you.
And vice versa, if
you're looking to expand,
potentially globally.
OLIVER HURST-HILLER:
I'll say that we are not.
And that sort of comes
back to our focus.
And also the challenge of
inequity in American education
is really large.
So we have plenty
of work to do here.
I think one of the cool
things for nonprofits and orgs
like Apple's are that, 14 years
ago when Charles had this idea,
he had to build the
whole thing from scratch.
And now, you don't
necessarily have to.
There's like white label,
crowdfunding platforms
out there.
And there's a
whole mess of them.
And also, I think a trend
is happening-- I'm biased.
But my experience is that
once you give in this way,
whether it's Kiva, or Globa
Giving, or us, or Kickstarter,
Indigo, once you have that level
of choice, and accountability,
and transparency,
it's really hard
to give another way,
like the old school,
throw it over the wall.
And, well, we agree
at the headline level
about the mission.
I'm going to I throw
this money over the wall.
So I think the good news.
There's now pressure on
foundations and nonprofits
to offer micro
giving opportunities,
and that sort of, Tim's
language, thin sliced ways
to target.
But I think the good
news is now it doesn't
mean everybody has to run
out, and like us, have
a product and
engineering team of 16.
There's now turnkey posted
products out there where
you can then take
your opportunities.
So maybe one thing, not
to put them on the spot,
but maybe one thing their
organization could look at
is giving donors
a way to target.
Because we know that
appeals to donors.
AUDIENCE: I just had one more.
Music education is
really close to me.
I was actually a music teacher
before I started [INAUDIBLE]
and got sucked
into the dark side.
But I think this is wonderful.
I've been a member
of DonorsChoose
since I saw it on
Colbert a few years ago.
And I've contributed a bunch of
different, like local schools
that have things like--
I contribute some money,
and say, oh, they seem far away.
But I'm very happy
to say that Google
came through and finished
like the last two projects
for us like [INAUDIBLE] and
instruments for small kids.
But I wanted to
know, do you have
an initiative for
music and arts?
It's really taken a hit in
the last 10 years in all
the schools. [INAUDIBLE].
Do you have a particular
initiative that you focus on?
OLIVER HURST-HILLER:
We tend to look
to the-- we're not prescriptive.
We look to the teachers.
And say, you tell
us what you need.
That said, teachers
are influenced
by the matching
dollars out there.
So when, for example,
orgs like Google
say, hey we want to focus
on STEM, teachers will say,
well, that's motivational to me.
Because I'd love to
activate this match.
And so you can sort of
draw attention to the area.
And it's absolutely the case
that music, and visual arts,
and performing arts, everybody
knows they're kind of the first
to get cut when times get tight.
And so we see a lot
of those projects
on the site sort of evergreen.
So if you guys ever want
to get behind projects
in the performing arts,
visual arts, music,
they're always on there
at different grade levels,
different need levels.
I think the good
news and bad news
there is that we're
probably always going
to have those
projects on our site.
Because it does seem
to be-- everybody
believes it's so
important to education.
But it's also sort of
the first to get cut
when times get tight.
AUDIENCE: I think some of those
voices are missing. [INAUDIBLE]
and those programs are done.
So that's why I'm
saying that maybe we
should organize something
that puts it back.
DIANE SOLINGER: I think there's
an opportunity for all of us
to be change agents
ourselves, right?
And we've got our
networks within Google,
and outside of Google.
And everybody can
be a philanthropist.
You don't have to be
$100,000 birthday match
to make that happen.
You can swipe your badge.
You can get other
people to join you.
So think about that.
Towards the end of this
year, first week of December,
many of our offices in
all of Mountain View
will be participating in
a program called G Give.
And in the month of
October, Googlers
will be invited to put forth
their organization that they
love, and share
their story about why
you love that organization.
And say, I'm going to sponsor
that organizations for a day.
And if you give to that
organization that day,
then Google will match it.
And I will match it up
to a certain amount.
So October starts this
nomination process.
It won't be totally global.
Because for us to
gift match globally
is a little bit challenging.
But it's going to be in
43 teams and offices.
And all of Mountain View
Bay Area will be covered.
And look for those messages
coming out in October.
If you have a charity that
you're really interested in,
and an organization
or cause around,
let's say, the music and
arts, put that forth.
And people will decide
in a democratic way
if that's one of the featured
organizations for the week.
And then you can bring
others into the fold
in the first week
of December when
the G Give campaigns happen.
TIM FERRISS: Just to
reiterate something.
It's not about the
amount of money you give.
It's about seeing the
direct result of the dollars
that you choose to put in.
So I think, whether it's
Apple's organization,
or DonorsChoose.org,
just see if you
can find a specific initiative
that reminds you of a teacher
or class that led you to doing
this as opposed to flat lining
or dropping like I'm
sure people have seen
their classmates suffer from.
Take the baby steps.
And we also hear
often from students
who its' really moving.
They're floored that a
stranger would help them.
And the way our
site works is they
don't know how much
money you gave,
whether it was $5,
or $50, or $500.
But you do leave a message.
You put your picture up there.
And you leave a message.
AUDIENCE: Lots of letters.
OLIVER HURST-HILLER:
You get letters back.
DIANE SOLINGER: That's
like Apple and his Dad.
He wrote the letters back.
So that personal connection--
OLIVER HURST-HILLER: It's
ultimately about people.
And that's, I think,
this very human thing
that probably goes
back tens of hundreds--
it's like in our DNA
to help each other.
And when these students
are on the receiving end,
they say, my gosh, these
strangers did this for me.
It's quite powerful.
TIM FERRISS: I had too
much caffeine today.
But just one more thing.
It's not just about
helping people.
Because help, I think--
it's about enabling people.
It's about trying to level
the playing field a bit
by giving them the
tools that they
need to be the highest
version of themselves.
It's not a handout, specifically
with both these orgs.
You're teaching
me with the code.
You're helping people
to acquire a skill,
whether that be something that
will return dividends forever
in music, or STEM, or elsewhere.
You're enabling them,
not just helping them.
I think it's helpful to
think of it this way.
OLIVER HURST-HILLER: That's
the power of education.
DIANE SOLINGER:
Thanks everybody.
And they'll be around
for a few minutes
if you want to
ask the questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]